this actually happened on Tuesday
Tuesday morning we got notification that
the the Irish boat was in distress from
the Irish coast guards at Malin Head we
made contact with a vessel and initially
they only required a pump just to pump
out water that was in the hole the Coast
Guard rescue helicopter from here at
Stornoway was was sent to the scene
which was about 50 miles north of the
the Outer Hebrides out in the North
Atlantic and upon arrival they put the
pump down to the crew on the board the
fishing boat but unfortunately these as
the pump didn't work and there's a
fishing boat continued to flood to the
extent where they decided to take two
crew off and airlift them to the sister
ship called the the sorry the Star of
Hope which was alongside the who don't
neither at the time as they were
attempting to do that so the boat
actually rolled over and that's where
you pick up the footage that that you've
been showing this morning and because of
the weather conditions up there they
were the seas were very rough with a
southerly force seven wind obviously and
that North Atlantic you get quite quite
a good swell going as well and and that
seems to be what was actually swept the
crew off the the side of the boat as as
it's sort of capsized and - and started
to sink this footage is just remarkable
and you can see the speed with which
it's happening in real time
these fishermen swept off that boat it
goes without saying how lucky they were
to have that crew the maritime Coast
Guard crew there to rescue them just how
difficult an operation is it to winch
people to safety in those kinds of
conditions in those in those sorts of
conditions that can be extremely tricky
for the helicopter crew especially in
those sort of sea conditions where the
boats and not only the boats moving up
and down but also so I decide the
the pilots have got to keep the aircraft
steady the winch operator as has got to
keep the winch the winch line tight and
he's got to keep control over that and
again you got the winch mundane in the
water there that's trying to pull the
people to safety in this particular case
two of the the fishing boats crew
managed to get into a life raft that
deployed as the boat sunk and their
sister ship picked them up they were
safe and well no harm at all the other
three members of the crew ended up in
the water as you can see from the
footage and they were all airlifted by
the helicopter back here to stornoway
suffering from mild hypothermia but I'm
happy to report that they were released
from hospital and the believers they're
now back home in the Ireland now you say
they were suffering from mild
hypothermia that was after being in the
water what for just a matter of minutes
if that helicopter hadn't been there
just how long were they survive for do
you think and at this time of year in
the North Atlantic we give the survival
time the sensible survival time that
somebody that's not wearing a life
jacket or any other type of buoyancy or
a survival so it could be as low as 15
to 20 minutes in these sorts of sea
temperatures